a former British soldier has died  fighting for the Russian forces in the  Ukrainian city of several Donetsk his  father has just posted this on Facebook  his name is Jordan gateley he served at  the British army up until March and then  after a careful consideration he went to  Ukraine to help that's according to his  father Dean who's made that post on  Facebook he left the British army as I  said back in March and announcing the  news on Facebook his father Dean said  yesterday we received the devastating  news that our son Jordan has been shot  and killed in a city of sovereign  his team say that they all loved him as  did we and he made a massive difference  to many people's lives not only  soldiering but also by training the  Ukrainian forces we all of course were  keeping across this for you and we'll  bring you more as and when we get it